spider-man homecoming is now in theaters
and I'm going to talk spoilers with you
guys where are my sleeves good question
I just really wanted to share with you
guys how truly white and pale I am and
something I've been holding back for a
long time realistically I just got a new
tattoo yesterday as of filming this you
guys have already seen this one I showed
you just a couple months ago but I'm
going to be continuing my sleeve down my
arm and I got fey and spike from Cowboy
Bebop
this artist is a genius I am in love
with what she can do and obviously it's
pretty you know swollen and disgusting
and red right now and will look better
when it's done but sleeves are pretty
much out of the question right now
because that thinks things like a 10
times sunburn SuperDuper depth machine
so no sleeves for a few days so you're
going to get a nice native Ohioan
looking person talking to you today so
you know I like to spiderman homecoming
I thought it was a lot of fun easily the
best spider-man movie in 13 years it
feels like yay spider-man's back and
he's actually good so all that aside
let's talk spoilers obviously the
biggest one was that the vulture Michael
Keaton is the dad of the girl that
Peters crushing on that actually really
surprised me and we contextualized the
entire film it was a good idea for the
villain as well because Marvel villains
have had a problem lately of just being
these evil guys that are in the movies
but this one now has a personal
connection something deeper with Peter
our hero because he's the dad of the
girl that Peters crushing on so they had
that great scene in the car and it just
added to film a lot more depth than it
would have had if he was just some guy
who was pissed off because Tony Stark
took away some of his money and some of
his jobs which is what the vulture
starts off as but that gives the film
more of an emotional current and it also
added something to the end of the film
as well because Peter decides to save
the vulture because he's the hero that
we all deserve and later when scorpion
comes up to him in jail possibly hinting
at the sinister six he won't give up
Peter
name so he has sort of a bond in a way
like a weird connection sort of like a
IOU one type situation with Peter which
I think really adds a lot to the film
and possibly to future films let's talk
about scorpion on the ferry sequence the
first time I noticed that this guy was
probably going to be scorpion was one of
the goons had a scorpion tattoo on his
neck and I was like to my wife I was
like he's a scorpion tattoo I think
that's supposed to be scorpion and sure
enough later you see him in the jail he
has sort of like some scarring here and
a scorpion tattoo I don't know I hope
that they don't just have him be some
goon with a scorpion tattoo I hope that
they go the route that the comics went
and actually give him some form of
abilities another villain that I
honestly did not know was in this movie
because I watched one trailer for
spider-man homecoming and I stayed away
from all other promotional material I
had no idea that shocker was going to be
in this or sort of shocker there's a guy
who's shocker
and then he's wiped out and another guy
replaced him as shocker so we have two
shockers and it's really just a guy who
has like this gauntlet that electrocutes
people if you get punched with it I
don't know I was disappointed with
shocker in this movie and I didn't
mention him in my spoiler free review
because I didn't know he was in the
movie I want to ruin it for anybody else
I don't know he was just like a guy with
a electrified gauntlet
it was very in his inclusion kind of
reminded me of the Rhino and amazing
spider-man 2 not the over-the-top insane
performance just the treatment of the
character just sort of in and out gone
like a quick little gust of wind and
then you forget about him almost
instantly another major spoiler is that
Peters classmate played by zendaya at
the end of the film she's like oh by the
way my name is MJ it was sort of like in
Dark Knight Rises when Joseph
gordon-levitt spoilers the Aventine Dark
Knight Rises is taking the form from
that lady and she's like you should use
your legal name I like that
Robin and I was like oh and they did it
again with MJ and that's basically the
same reaction I had Oh hmm
I have no problem with
mary-jane that isn't white that doesn't
have red hair I honestly don't care if
they had gone to Miles Morales route
with spider-man I would have been fine
with that too that doesn't bother me
I like the comics like all different
types of incarnations of these
characters I just didn't really find her
character all that interesting she kind
of acted strange and dopey like she was
in detention saying I'm just here to
draw people who look sad like what but
at the central relationship of Peter and
MJ in the comics it's really the
quirkiness that they have with each
other the play back and forth that makes
those characters so much fun and I can
see the seeds planted for that to really
blossom in future movies so I really
don't have a problem with it I was just
like oh she's NJ okay whatever it wasn't
like something when I was like oh that's
so great Wow it was just kind of like
okay she's ended there's also something
with homecoming that I'm a little
unclear on because as I watched it it
seemed like they were not including that
spider-man has spidey sense there's
never a moment where he seems to notice
something instinctually and avoid it in
fact there's a lot of times where things
sneak up on him the vulture sneaks up
behind him many times Ned in his room
finds out that he's spider-man and he
didn't even know that he was there and
so I was like okay they're just not
including the spidey sense all right I
mean I wish they had included it the
suit basically tells him everything and
I didn't like that I thought that was
like okay he's just using a suit he's
not Iron Man he's spider-man so I really
loved how he had to give this suit up
and then become a hero without it I
thought that was fantastic
this is why I'm confused though Kevin
Feige has since come out and said yes he
absolutely does have spider sense
we just didn't utilize it from a
over-the-top theatrical perspective like
the past films we never show like him
going like this and you hear a noise
like in Raimi's he just has it
apparently oh my spider sense is
tingling
if you know what I'm talking about I
don't know about that comment actually
part of that comment seems sneakily like
he's trying to cover for the fact that
they didn't include spidey-sense because
there's so many moments in this movie
where he should have noticed things and
he didn't and I'm like okay if you
didn't include it just own up to it and
be like we're not doing the spidey sense
thing but if you are including it maybe
don't have vultures sneak up behind
spider-man and have him not notice
because that's just not how it works
what this movie did so well is capture
that high school movie feel very much so
like Ferris Bueller's Day Off there's
even a scene where you can see Ferris
playing on a TV in the background at
some party it's very much so a
recreation of that John Hughes type feel
except Peter Parker and spider-man their
super powers and super villains and I
thought that worked really well the MCU
stuff sometimes felt like an added
addition Pepper Potts shows up so I
guess Gwyneth Paltrow is still involved
with these movies and I like the stuff
with happy though because Jon Favreau I
love that guy
I love him as a filmmaker I love him as
an actor and I liked all the stuff with
him I especially love the opening short
film that Peter was making I thought
that was really clever there's a lot of
great ideas in this movie and despite
the fact that I still like spider-man 1
in spider-man 2 more it's easily the
best since then I think this movie is
setting up really great potential future
spider-man movies and that's a problem
with MCU movies because some really
standalone really well and some feel
like setup movies no this is nowhere
near as bad as like the amazing
spider-man 2 or every two seconds
there's a reference to another sequel I
really like what they did with the
character I thought Tom Holland was
brilliant I really like Michael Keaton
as well this is actually a pretty
entertaining villain and as I said they
gave him a personal connection this time
around with the hero he wasn't just like
some evil guy he's doing evil stuff I
think they really got a lot of it right
so for future spider-man movies what I
would really like to see is obviously a
great incarnation of venom on screen as
well as carnage people always forget
about carnage you know what talks about
carnage carnage is so f
cool but if they decide to go the Kraven
route which I would love because they
have never done Kraven I really hope
that filmmakers read Cravens last hunt
this is probably my favorite Spidey
graphic novel it's excellent if you've
never read it please pick it up it's so
good and if you decide to do Kraven
filmmakers out there please check out
that graphic novel they really nailed
the portrayal of the character so yeah
I'm super curious to know what you guys
all thought of spider-man homecoming I
think it's a really fun spider-man movie
not without flaws but a really good one
and it's really nice to finally say that
also I hope you checked out my first
episode of infinite lives it's a new
show I'm doing a couple of times a month
a friend and I will get together and
we'll play a bunch of games and a
certain franchise leading up to a movie
and just have fun there's no real
structure to it it's just meant to have
like a laid-back segment that I can do
with some friends and have a good time
with you guys and also I've gotten a lot
more requests to do more game content
and so I'm trying to do that for you
guys as well I did spider-man games with
my good buddy and I hope you guys check
that out and I just want to say thank
you so much to collective tattoos there
in Stowe Ohio this is not a paid
sponsorship in fact they even were like
you don't have to do this I'm like you
guys are amazing be Hendrix if you guys
want to tattoo be Hendrix collective
tattoos she's a genius
she did both of mine she did my science
crop circle and my fan spike she owns
tattoos she is so good definitely check
her out if you guys want some new ink
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]